hi there today we're looking at
pre-trained transformers
as universal computation engines by
kevin liu
adita grover pieter abiel and igor
mordach
on a high level this paper argues that
pre-trained transformers
specifically transformers pre-trained on
language modeling
are doing something called universal
computation
and the way they prove it is by
transfer learning these transformers to
completely
new domains so not language modeling
they do things
like xor tasks or c410 so computer
vision
they transfer learn these transformers
to these completely
new domains and they don't just do it in
a regular transfer learning way
they freeze almost all of the parameters
of that transformers
specifically they freeze all of the
attention and all of the feet forward
layers in the transformer
therefore they only fine tune about .01
or so or 0.1 of the parameters of the
model
and they show that on these specific
tasks these
frozen pre-trained transformers as you
can see right here
are competitive if not outperforming a
transformer that is
fully trained from scratch on these
tasks
and it also mostly outperforms lstms
that are
fully trained from scratch on these
tasks
so this is pretty interesting and it
gives rise to a number of
sort of questions about what happens in
these transformers
so we're going to look at what the
claims are and what the
let's the evidence brought forth by this
paper is
about why language pre-trained
transformers are
universal computation engines and
yeah i'll have some comments on my own
as always if you do
like content like this share it out
leave a like and tell me what you think
is going on here in the comments
right so the abstract reads we
investigate the capability of
transformer pre-trained on natural
language to generalize to other
modalities
with minimal fine-tuning okay and they
say in particular without
fine-tuning of the self-attention and
feed-forward layers of the residual
blocks
so as you know or as you might know a
transformer is built approximately
like this so what you have is you have
input
so you have the positional embeddings
and you have the
input embeddings now if it is a language
model
that is simply one vector for every word
or word piece
if it is an image model like in the
vision transformer in the vip
it is you simply take the image
and you make it into these patches
and then each pack patch you simply
unroll the patch
into one long vector so you simply
unroll the pixels
and that is a patch and that in the
sequence of such
patches is your inputs now
what follows is these self-attention
blocks and this is the majority of the
transformer
is l times the self-attention blocks you
always have
a attention layer and if you if you
don't know what an attention layer is
i'm sure you'll find some video on
youtube that explains it
um this is followed by
layer norm this is followed by a
element-wise feed-forward layer
and it is again followed by a layer norm
you also
have the residual connections as you can
see
right here and then all of this is
followed by
an output layer and the output layer is
very task specific
in language modeling it's obviously
classifying
into the vocabulary so into one of
whatever the 30 000 possible
continuations
in computer vision it might be
classifying into
the classes of the data set so for
example in imagenet
you'd have a thousand classes or 21 000
depending on which
which version you use so what they're
saying
is they are not fine-tuning
they are freezing the multi-head
attention
and they're also freezing the feet
forward layers now these make up like 99
some percent of the transformer
so what they get is they get a frozen
pre-trained transformers and frozen
specifically refers to these
parts i marked in blue in fact they
just keep the attention and they keep
the feed forward layers as
they come out of the of the language
pre-training
and then they train the things on
different tasks
so these tasks are as follows there's
bit memory
they consider a bit memory task where
the model is shown five bit strings
each of length 1000 afterwards the model
is shown a masked version of one of the
bit strings
where each bit is masked with
probability 0.5 and a model is tasked
with
reproducing the original bit strings so
you give it
you give it five bit strings in sequence
and then you give it a sixth one that is
kind of corrupted
and the model must figure out which one
of these five
it is and then it must successfully
reproduce
that bit string so if it figures out
it's probably numbered so
the model has to look at the overlap
between the strings and then
where there's the most overlap it needs
to copy over
that string or the non-overlapping parts
so this is a fairly um complicated task
for
a model like this that is just trained
with backprop right
there is bitxor where you have two
bit strings of length five and you need
to
compute the element wise xor this is a
long-standing difficult task for
neural networks we know that there is
list ops where you get a sequence
like this and you must compute the
result so it's
acting a little bit like a calculator so
now it turns actually out that
if you think of the bit memory that's
already pretty similar to language right
bitxor maybe not list ops we're going to
see that these models perform
fairly poorly on the list ops
task and then the last one is computer
vision so mnist and c410
is the classic like vision transformer
uh
domain where but still they take the
transformer that's pre-trained on
language and simply
fine-tune the positional embeddings the
input embeddings
the output layer and the layer norm
parameters
that's all they do and the last one is
c410 from the long range arena
where instead of forming patches like
this in the
long range arena task you simply take
every single
uh pixel into as its own
kind of so you don't do patches anymore
you do you unroll pixel by pixel
that is significantly longer uh vector
for the model to to compute over so it's
going to make the task a bit more
difficult
because you completely lose all
localization information
and the last one is this remote homology
detection it's a task
from protein folding okay so
how do these how do these things do
you've already seen this
here in the overview namely
if you train these things on these
bit tasks so bit memory or bits or you
can see
that a if you the frozen transformer
here
reaches a hundred percent so does the
full transformer
so what that shows you it's not
necessarily which one's better it's just
that
both are comp are able to completely
solve this task
well for example an lstm is not
that we have no idea here what the size
of the lstm is i don't think they
stated anywhere so the comparison with
an lstm
it is cool to see that the lstm doesn't
get this relatively simple task but it
also might just be a function of
how large the lstm is and how much rigor
goes into training one nevertheless the
lstm
can't solve it and that's because the
lstm takes in a sequence
as just one at a time and it needs to
sort of
remember in its hidden state uh what the
individual elements are
and it can't go back right the
transformer can always look back
the lstm needs to remember everything
and i think that makes it much harder to
do these kind of sequence tasks
i already told you list stops
they all perform badly but interestingly
they perform
equally badly so the full transformer
here is no better
than the frozen transformer which is
very interesting
um if you look at mnist and c410
actually all of the other tasks you'll
see that the
frozen transformer is not worse than the
full transformer in fact it's sometimes
better
and that is going to be an interesting
um
an interesting thing also to look at so
the whole paper is actually just
ablation studies into this phenomenon
like why does this happen
and it's very cool and um
the result is going to be so the authors
claim
that there is something special about
language pre-training
that already primes the transformer
to be receptive to these new tasks
now there are two different
possibilities if you if you think uh
what's happening here
actually let's first go to the ablations
and do the discussion at the end because
once you see what is happening um
you'll have you'll be able to form your
own opinion
what i would like to remind you though
of
is that they do pre they do
train these layer norm sorry
they do train the layer norm parameters
right
so when i saw this when i when i saw
this and they said
well we only train the input embeddings
because of course it's a different
modality so
adjusting the input embeddings makes
sense right and the positional
embeddings may be two
and the output layer because we have a
different task that makes sense too and
the rest
we freeze but we also adjust the layer
norm parameters
right but we don't adjust the attention
my immediate thought was you probably
probably
tried doing it without the layer norm
parameters at the beginning they
probably tried just adjusting input and
output embeddings
and that probably didn't work too well
and in the ablations you're actually
going to see this
so um and there i think this
hinges on the fact and we've seen this
with transformers before i think
they're called adapter layers so if you
have your kind of transformer
layers one after another what you can do
is you can build in these
adapter layers that have very few
parameters that are kind of compressing
and
uncompressing the the data and that's a
way you can fine tune the transformer so
this kind of goes in
and out again in dimensionality that is
a way you can
adapt and we we know that these things
are very possible
with transformers that you can sort of
have the transformer
ready and then only adjust very few
parameters to transfer learn
and i think the same is going on here
now what the
the authors sort of hint at is that
in in the schematically if you have the
transformer you have the attention part
which is sort of the cross information
routing part right
and then after that you have the feed
forward part
which is element wise like this and then
you
sort of have a layer norm part and the
layer norm part
what it essentially is in terms of
learnable parameter
is that you take one element here or
even one channel
or one layer and and this depends on the
exact type of norm
but you in the input signal you have
two parameters that you learn so your
output of the layer norm
is going to be a normalized x so this is
a normalization and you do it either
over the bachelor over the layer or
something like this
in layer norm you do it over the layer
and you have two parameters that you can
learn
one is a scaling and one is an offset
and i think you know by learning these
you can adapt and this is this is i
think these two things
have a lot of relation to each other
even though the authors say
we don't learn any of the attention i
can
by influencing this a and this b right
here
and this y then goes into the next layer
of attention i can very much
influence how the attention works right
if the y
is then in the next layer
from the y i construct the
w sorry i construct the
the keys queries and values give of this
particular element and that decides
what information gets routed where and
so on
so i have very much an influence over
the
over the attention in the next layer by
adjusting this
a i might not have a direct influence
like i can only
if of course if i want to change
something in an element in the
key an effect of this because i have to
change the y
as a whole is going to be that also
change something in here
but certainly backprop will figure out
some way i can make this happen
okay so i i think this this whole notion
of um we don't influence the attention
at all
it's not as clear-cut it's true they
don't change the attention parameters
however they are very they are a lot
able to influence how information is
routed by changing the signal itself
in these layer norm parameters also they
here they call it
zero shot uh they say
improves performance and compute
deficiency on non-language downstream
tests in particular we find that such
pre-training enables
the frozen pre-trans transformers to
generalize in zero shot
to these modalities zero shot i think
that's a bit
of an it's a bit of an over claim
like i get it you you pre-train whatever
how many
few percent like um only fine tuning
0.1 of the total number of parameters of
the transformer model
and none of the self-attention
parameters i don't think
it's entirely fair to call this zero
shot
unless i completely overseen and misread
the paper which of course is
possible because i'm just one per person
uh
reading a paper okay
so again we fine tune
the output layer the input layer the
layer norm parameters and the positional
embeddings
um my claim is this here does most of
the work
like we know we already know that for
for example for cnns
uh we can do a we can take a randomly
initialized cnn and by just
adjusting the batch norm parameters we
can already gain a non-trivial
uh result and i think the
layer norm here is doing a lot of the
work of course the input and output
layer
as well we also know that we can take
like a randomly initialized neural
network and simply training an output
layer can already also give us a good
performance this is all stuff they do in
this paper
however i think the layer norm does a a
lot of the
a lot of the crucial work here uh
to but there are still some interesting
things that come out of these
experiments
uh because it's not just that okay
so as i said the paper is a big piece of
ablation
studies oh yeah that's what i forgot the
interesting thing of course is that
the fully trained transformer isn't
better right that's the interesting
thing like if you fully train
a transformer on the same tasks and this
is
due i think and i think the paper agrees
due to the fact
that we are in sort of the low data
regime at least for the things here that
are like the natural data sets like
mnist or
c410 we don't have too many we don't
have too many
uh data points so training a big
transformer
with all the parameters could even be
counterproductive because we're just
going to
over fit or shoot ourselves in the foot
all right let's go through these
experiments
can pre-trained language models transfer
to different modalities
and the answer here is going to be yes
absolutely so their base thing is like a
gpt-2
model that is trained on language and
it's so interesting right that if you
transfer to these tasks
and you can see uh right here you
compare it
the so these are the results from figure
one this is just
what you saw in the bar diagram again
it's
pretty interesting that these fully the
frozen
pre-trained transformers uh match the
performance of the full and
outperform the lstms on these tasks
pretty cool so in some tasks you can see
right here in the homology
they even outperform the fully trained
transformers
the second one what is the importance of
the pre-training modality
so here they're going to compare what if
we just
randomly initialize the transformer and
then keep just keep
we freeze the same layers but they're
not trained or randomly initialized
or we pre-train it on this bit uh
memory tasks this is just this one task
or we pre-train it on
imagenet imagenet21k in fact we
so we pre-train instead of one language
on images
or we pre-train on languages this is
this fpt is
pre-trained on languages which one is
going to be
the best so this is to counter people
they're making the claim that language
modeling has a specific
specific property that language
is sort of a good task to pre-train
these transformers
better than other modalities so you
can't just pre-train the transformer on
any old task that's what they're saying
here that language is somehow special or
the best out of these ones
so in order to demonstrate that you can
see right here
the this is the language one the
randomly initialized one
already kind of underperforms
throughout here so actually not that
much
in these things here but you can see on
mnist or on c410
it it does not perform too well all
across
the bit memory one obviously performs
well in the bit memory task that's what
it was pre-trained on
but also it kind of sucks on the rest of
these tasks it's okay
in mnist it's the performance is kind of
shaky and the vision transformer is
better
but it still lags behind except on
c410 uh because you know being
pre-trained as a vision model
might you know it it seems like
it's okay that it performs well on image
modeling
the whole point here though is to
generalize
two domains out of your free training
thing
and on these domains the language one is
better than all the other ones
now the question there is multiple
questions here
i think it is a bit too early from just
this paper to say that
language modeling has this special
property right
what i think might also be an
explanation is for example how difficult
is your pre-training task
now when you look at language modeling
you can look at simply how many classes
does it have so the number of classes
is in language modeling something like
30k like these vocabularies are fairly
large
random it's absolutely nothing these
bit memory tasks is
so you have two classes and in the
vision transformer you have 21k classes
but you only
need to apply it once per sequence right
you only have to have one output
whereas in language modeling you need to
output every single
so every single token is a
classification so in in fact
the this is not necessarily more classes
but it is
let's say more training examples per
training data point that you get because
every token is a training example
essentially so it might
not be a language thing it might just be
how
how hard the task is in terms of number
of classes and how much training data
you have available
i think there are a lot of variables
that they haven't necessarily
controlled for here and it might be a
bit too early to say language modeling
is the
task though what i'm completely prepared
to accept is to say language modeling is
a good task in fact it's the best task
out of these ones but
i think the it could be a cool
it could be cool to research more in
this direction and say okay can we find
a better task can we
find a task that is even more complex
and that depends
on what is really going on here so i see
two possibilities
possibility one why this even works
is to say that somehow natural
signals are all somehow equal
so pre-training on language somehow
makes the transformer the attention
layers just
adjust themselves to the sort of natural
signals that we see around us so
when we feed in an image recognition
task or any other task that
kind of humans care about in the natural
world the transformer is already sort of
prepared
about what that could entail like about
the types of computation
and then second of all uh and
this this is different this is simply um
with enough complexity you see there is
simply
uh what i'm going to say computational
putational utility
computational utility
what i mean by that is that there are
sim
when when you pre-train on a task
certain types of computation are going
to be important for that task
and the more complex and the bigger your
model
the more sort of prim computational
primitives you can encode
into the attention layers now
when you encode these computational
primitives it's not necessarily
of course it has something to do with
the type of signal
but i think what's up what could be
happening is that
these transformers they simply
they prepare a lot of good features that
are just
useful to compute different stuff like
x4 like remembering things
and so on i think this could definitely
be the case that in these attention
layers there are these just
computational primitives
encoded and if you pre-train on a task
and the harder the task is the more of
these
primitives need to be encoded
and what you do when you adjust the
layers in between
is simply that you recombine
these primitives in a better way but
sort of all of the computational
primitives are already there
i think i think the two are not
necessarily even exclusive and i think
the paper hints at
both might be playing a role right here
i don't think they say exactly the same
thing
but this would also give sort of meaning
to this word of computation or
universal computation engine they're of
the
these transformers and we might even
extend that to probably any machine
learning model
if we could scale it up and train it
correctly
probably evolves or trains to have these
computational primitives
inside of it and that's why we can
adjust it with just a little bit
now they're going to claim
um there is something about language
pre-training
later so first of all they say how
important is the transformer
architecture
and here they simply say if we take a
randomly initialized transformer
and compare it with a randomly
initialized lstm we freeze
we freeze the attention layers and then
we just do
our frozen training then the transformer
performs
a lot better than the lstm here in most
actually all of the tasks
however this is a very shaky comparison
of course because
how do you fairly compare a transformer
architectures within lstm architectures
do you control number of parameters
number of computation
speed i don't know okay so i don't know
what's fair
next does language pre-training improve
efficiency over random initialization
the answer is
yes it converges much faster if you
pre-train with
language and do the frozen
attention layers attend to modality
specific tokens so here they're just
going to look
at the first attention layer and they
see that the attention matrix for
example in this big sore task
attends so here are the two here are the
two
this is string number one this is string
number two and in the output
from here you need to compute the the
xor
you can see that the attention first is
it's on the on the first one and then
it's also
on the second one right in the output it
always looks at the corresponding
position
so here you can see clearly that the
attention matrix
already attends to the correct things
for the task
which is cool because we've never
trained the attention
right but it's i think that goes into my
claim that
look um we are still able to influence
the attention matrix even though we
don't train the attention
weights we are able to influence it by
training these in between parameters
the same goes for these bit memory tasks
you can see the attention matrices
are very much attuned to the task
right here next one does
freezing the transformer prevent
overfitting or
underfitting and here they uh they train
this frozen transformer and they compare
it to
training a transformer that just has
three
layers so they say
our general finding is that in contrast
to their fully trained counterparts
fpt models underfit the data which lends
them to further improvements by
increasing
model capacity so if you compare it
to a three layer transformer the three
layer transformer
does outperform the
12 layer frozen transformer however
it does so by reaching a much higher
training accuracy so
overfitting is much more of a problem if
you fully train the transformer
however if you use this frozen
transformer you're probably
under fitting as you can see right here
so you could technically scale up and
gain
more power with this frozen fine tuning
does performance scale with model size
yes
so you can see as you increase from
small to medium to large as you increase
the number of
layers the performance increases however
the performance also increases for a
randomly initialized one so it just
seems to be like
the more parameters the better it's the
same and here is something i find
interesting
can performance be attributed simply to
better statistics for initializations
here they're going to
let's say make the point that there is
something about language model
pre-training that actually
makes the transformer conducive to
all these tasks and you can't just reach
that
by better initialization which
is more point one from here than point
two because point two you could just
reach by initializing
in a better way like this we could we
could characterize these computational
primitives
and we could build them in from the
start whereas natural signals
we can't characterize them otherwise we
wouldn't need machine learning
so what they're going to do is they're
simply going to
take a fully trained transformer
which they call an oracle and then they
they're going to compute the mean
and the standard deviation so the the
gaussian
from those and then they're going to
initialize
this new transformer so they're going to
take the pre-trained which they have
they're going to do default which is the
randomly initialized one we've already
seen those one as well
and then they're going to take a
randomly initialized one
but not randomly with a default
randomization but randomly
with the statistics they got from the
oracle so this transformer is going to
be randomly initialized but it has the
same
statistics as the uh as the full
transformer or as a trained transformer
so the statistics are correct
and that does not seem it seems to help
a little bit
as you can see but it does not seem to
help in fact
here it even it even hurts however i
think that's a bit of a weak experiment
and i think there is still a possibility
that we could
initialize these transformers much
better if we could
if we could correctly capture the
essence of these computational
primitives that are
there in that are learned by gradient
descent i think if we can
capture those in a theoretically sound
way
we might be able to initialize or if we
could just
yeah if we could find like a not a
natural language but if we could find a
synthetic pre-training task that is just
so hard
but it completely initializes all of
these computational primitives
that might still be better and that's
going to be the ultimate experiment that
differentiates between
option one natural language pre-training
is somehow important because
of grammar and natural signals or option
two
what we're doing is just inputting
computational primitives into these
layers
does fine-tuning self-attention and
feed-forward layers further improve
performance and the answer is actually
no it degrades
you can see right here this is worse
than this and that's because probably of
over fitting if you fine-tune the whole
transformer
you're going to fall down and now here
is where it
really comes in that you know these
tasks they
are in the low data regime i know if you
go back five years that sounds
ridiculous
but right now they are these things will
over
fit if you train everything
and here it comes which parameters of
the model are important to fine tune
and you can go look at the you can go
look at the look at the table it's in
the appendix
but they say
in particular we find orthogonal
initialization
wait we run ablations
here we generally find the layer norm
parameters to be
most important the layer norm parameters
all right and that sort of gives
it gives a gives credence to the fact
this is not
so the i think what what they're doing
yeah these layer norms they carry a lot
of the weight
of these things right here it's still
pretty cool because they're very few
parameters that you need to fine-tune
and okay now they do a bunch of more
ablations like only training the output
layer which gives non-trivial
performance but not
a good enough performance so
and yeah for some reason i have
another set of the paper right here but
this was essentially the paper it's very
cool
and the paper is super i think it's well
written and it's
easy to read because it's like hey here
is a phenomenon
we've discovered and now we're just
going to investigate all kinds of things
that explain this phenomenon
we're going to rule out uh some stuff
some hypotheses and we're going to
arrive at some kind of conclusion in
here
and yeah that was my two cents to this
paper
i hope you enjoyed it it's a bit of a
shorter video and bye bye